did lobotomies work uh I'm ashamed to
say this as a psychiatrist but
absolutely not so lobotomies were a
cruel quite an evil Twisted thing so
lobotomies remove your prefrontal cortex
or either the actual part of your brain
or the connections to it and this part
of your brain is responsible for things
like executive functions so decision
making uh
planning understanding emotions and sort
of sequencing out your thoughts and your
behaviors by removing that you stop all
the issues with that and it was invented
for diseases like schizophrenia bipolar
but the problem is it it kind of made it
turned patients into zombies at a
stretch you could say that it was it it
improved the conditions of some patients
who were so extreme and so uncontained
in their emotions and so violent that
they became kind of docile dribbling
wrecks but obviously this is a very
cruel thing to happen so in the 60s and
70s people realized that that the the
the cons heavily outweighed the pros